So after his event with women where he made
the big announcement that he's pardoning Susan
B. Anthony, who's been dead for almost 120
years.
Trump did another event in Yuma, Arizona.
And this was really a house of horrors.
Donald Trump came out of his plane and his
first statement was right away that because
he caught sleepy Joe spying on him, which
is treason.
He should get another four years on top of
the four years he's seeking now.
Take a look at this.
And, you know, considering that we called
President Obama and sleepy Joe Biden spying
on our campaign treason, we'll probably be
entitled to another four more years if.
Now, I know when Trump does this, a lot of
people say, David, this doesn't even deserve
attention because he won't get a third term.
Of course he won't.
But what deserves attention is that his followers
buy into this stuff.
They are so easily convinced that, hey, yeah,
it was unfair.
Trump should get a third term because of Obama
and Biden, despite it all being made up.
And it all being ridiculous.
And this one got bad very, very quickly.
This next clip might be the top instance of
projection that I've seen from Donald Trump
saying the Biden campaign is cult like.
If you can imagine that we're talking about
abolishing prisons.
Biden's campaign has turned into a go for
open border and other zealots, by the way,
they want to double and triple your taxes.
Trump wondered aloud about injecting bleach
and alcohol to treat Corona virus, and many
of his followers stood behind him saying,
you know, maybe it's not such a bad idea.
And Trump says the Biden campaign is like
a cult.
Yeah, the Biden campaign has fallen for the
cult of prioritizing democracy and competence
in the Oval Office.
That's the Biden cult that we have.
There's actually a lot that's interesting
here.
And so first there's the projection, which
with Trump is huge.
He often accuses others of that which he himself
is guilty of, or he accuses the followers
of Biden of that which his followers actually
are guilty of.
But also the cult like nature of Trump's followers
is a topic of academic inquiry.
It's not just, oh. Trump says Biden followers
are cultists.
But Trump's own followers are really the cultists.
This has been studied academically.
We interviewed cult expert Steven Hassin about
cults and how the Trump.
I don't.
I'm looking for a word other than cult to
say it's like a cult.
The the base of Trump is very cult like.
So the projection is particularly acute here.
And then Donald Trump suggests that were it
not for him, we might not have the Second
Amendment right now.
The Second Amendment would be gone if Trump
weren't president.
And she's running against a gentleman who
is when you read what he's done, when you
read what he said about the Second Amendment
and about all other things.
You're not going to want to vote.
You're not going to want to have them play
with your Second Amendment.
I'll tell you what.
If I weren't president, I don't believe you'd
have a Second Amendment right now.
I don't think the pressure that was put on
this is also another one of these features
or bugs, depending on how you look at it,
of Donald Trump's personality issues.
This is a delusion of grander right.
The Second Amendment of the Constitution has
been around since 1791.
It's been two hundred, twenty nine years.
It has nothing to do with Donald Trump.
It remaining doesn't require Donald Trump
to get rid of it.
You would need a new and that amendment and
that just would not happen.
There's just the Second Amendment is completely
safe and Trump has nothing to do with it being
safe.
And then right in the middle of a xenophobic,
racist rant about murderers and killers, trump
short circuits right in the middle of the
word removals.
That thing happened where he glitches on a
word and his right shoulder spasms.
You have to watch it to understand it.
Let's take a quick look in facilities.
This would make removing illegal aliens totally
impossible.
And you would have murderers, killers, rapists
in your midst.
I don't think so.
Immediately suspend all removes, triggering
a tidal wave of really a flood.
If you think a flood.
So anyway, every day Trump doing some kind
of event like this, clearly not liking the
DNC and the attention that Joe Biden is getting.
And each event is worse than the previous,
more embarrassing.
And the really embarrassing thing on top of
Trump, it's doing these events is that no
matter what Trump says, there is always a
crowd that will cheer for it.
It doesn't matter how absurd, how ridiculous,
how unconstitutional.
Trump can always get a group of supporters
together.
He can find a group no matter what.
That will cheer for anything he says.
And that's the really scary part, because
when we step back and we say what has happened
to the country over the last three and a half
years, what is the future of the country?
Trump is one person when you find 63 million
people to vote for it.
That's the real indictment of the country.
And as I said before, if Trump wins, he'll
probably win with around 65 or 66 million
votes.
If Trump loses in November, he will lose with
likely between 60 and 65 million votes.
And even if he is not the president, starting
on January 20th, those 60 plus million people
who are going to vote for him, they still
will live here.
They will still be a problem that we have
to contend with.
And I won't redo that analysis because I did
it recently enough.